Що серце підскаже.
Це стосується всього, що ми робимо.
Якісь маленькі речі або великі.
Ми знаходимось в селі Бурти.
З таким чудовим краєвидом.
Ми тут живемо і ми тут ліпимо з глини.
Спілкуємося з людьми, продаємо кераміку,
п'ємо чай, вони приїжджають в гості,
або просто на майстер класи,
насолоджуємося життям
і живемо в цілому.
Тут у нас кухня,
тут стелажі з сирим [продуктом],
майстерня, гончарне коло.
Це Павло зробив з колеса
першого трамвая чеського:
він має велику інертність.
Ми беремо переважно українську глину
з Донецької області — це Слов'янськ.
Там усім відомі
дуже якісні керамічні маси.
Вони вже готові до роботи.
Ми ще не знайшли матеріал у цій місцевості,
але ми шукаємо.
Мені здається, що ми знайдемо щось цікаве.
Ми комбінуємо, шукаємо якийсь свій мікс.
Потім ліпимо або на [гончарному] колі
або так, руками, як тисячі років тому.
Потім воно сохне,
а потім опал.
Двічі на рік зазвичай у нас опал у дров'яній печі.
Навесні та восени.
Такий ритм роботи.
Це дров'яна піч.
Саме сьогодні був перший опал,
їх взагалі два проходять кожного разу.
На перший опал
кераміка запікається частково.
Далі ми її виймаємо і вже робимо з поливою.
Тобто два опали за один раз виходить.
Зараз, на цьому тижні, буде ще один опал, але вже у поливі.
Для того, щоб виріб був максимально вологотривким.
Я проводжу тут, здебільшого,
весну, частково літо і осінь.
Я познаймився з Павлом у Дніпрі
на одному з ярмарків кераміки.
І захотів спробувати щось зробити своїми руками.
І навесні я приїхав,
це було п'ять років тому, вже напевно шість.
З цього почався мій шлях.
Павло їздив Полтавщиною і шукав місце
для того, щоб побудувати піч дров'яну.
І знайшов саме це місце,
бо ви самі бачите наскільки воно гарне.
Тут є схил саме такий, як треба,
для того, щоб побудувати [піч].
І взагалі вся атмосфера надихає творити прекрасне.
Я спочатку продавав тут,
на ярмарках, знайомим архітекторам.
Виробляли на замовлення речі для інтер'єрів.
Потім масово розкрився Інтернет, Facebook.
І потрошку-потрошку наші роботи побачив світ.
Перше таке визнання — це мене запросили
на виставку з Нью-Йоркської галереї.
Це було у 2012 році, мабуть.
Інтернет — це диво 21 сторіччя.
Ми зараз змішуємо глазурі.
Ми шукаємо білу глазур, вона в нас основна.
Тому що посуд для чаю найкращий — це білий.
У білій чашці колір чаю розкривається,
він стає очевидним, чистим.
Кожен опал ми шукаємо якусь свою комбінацію.
Декілька глазурей, додаємо
легкоплавку глину червону.
І кожного разу це по-різному трішечки.
Нам цікаво, щоб глазур тріскалась, по-перше.
Тобто ми намагаємося створити так званий цек.
Керамісти, які працюють на заводах,
його не люблять, бо це — брак,
а для нас — це краса.
Зараз ми завантажуємо електричну невеличку піч.
Робимо тестовий опал на глазурі,
щоб з'ясувати перед великим опалом,
де у нас які глазурі,
щоб підібрати необхідний нам колір.
Повага до Всесвіту.
Для мене таке ставлення до природи —
це природньо.
Бо я з дитинства захоплювався тваринним світом.
Я закінчив біофак за фахом зоолог.
Дуже багато подорожував.
І по Україні, і по середній Азії.
Дуже захоплювався цим.
Мені подобається така цитата
відомого в Україні архітектора:
«По землі треба ходити пошепки».
Це наше спільне бачення.
Якщо з'явиться ще людина,
яка поділяє мій світогляд, мій однодумець,
з якою буде спільне бачення світу,
таке як у нас з Михайлом,
то звісно я захочу з ним працювати
і збільшити кількість [виробів].
Але сама по собі кількість не має значення.
Має значення якість взаємодії.
На сьогоднішній день наших з Михайлом чашок
немає тільки на двох континентах:
в Антарктиді і в Африці.
Це дуже приємно, це дає нам фідбек.
Дає кошти на життя, на розвиток.
Це — досягнення, так.
Для таких людей розслаблених,
які живуть своїм життям у природі, – це досягнення.
Що вони можуть заробляти цим.